every year the US Postal Service is on
average 41 pounds of junk mail to you to
achieve that feat companies spend 47
billion dollars a year to get that
garbage in your mailbox it's a nuisance
and all that paper adds up to 26 million
trees being cut down each year just for
junk mail most of it going to the
landfill forty-four percent of it never
even opened also every day fifty four
billion spam emails are sent that's
eight pieces of spam for every man woman
and child on earth per day you've got
mail and also everyday telemarketers
call 80 million people in the US with
courtesy calls which is such a
shamelessly ironic term that it has all
but obliterated the meaning the courtesy
this has led most people to not even
answer a number if it's not in their
contact list and all of this just boils
down to being annoying to you and
ultimately waste your time every second
you have to spend during away mail
sorting emails or screening calls
luckily people like us have already
complained in the past and solutions
have been created for these problems the
problem is they aren't very well known
or advertised so people aren't taking
advantage of it and we're about to
change that junk mail to solutions first
DM a choice org the DMA is the largest
direct marketing organization in the US
and they send most of the junk mail that
you get on this website you can opt out
from receiving junk mail from any and
all of their advertisers there's a two
dollar processing fee but it will keep
you off their do not contact mailing
lists for ten years so I think it's
worth it second opt-out pre-screened com
it's a free service that puts you on a
do not mail list for credit cloud and
interest okay
next spam email we're going to use DMA
choice or for this again on that same
website you can also opt out from
hearing from any of their companies by
email and this will last six years and
it's free also make sure you have a
gmail account which has a great spam
filter okay finally courtesy calls do
not call gov have you ever entered an
unknown number just to hear this
congratulations you've been selected to
receive a free cruise to the Bahamas
well the Federal Trade Commission has
started a Do Not Call Registry that
makes it illegal for telemarketers to do
that to you it's free and it takes two
minutes to sign your number up it
doesn't expire so you never have to
renew this and any telemarketer caught
calling anyone on this list will be
fined up to forty thousand dollars
alright that's it you can knock all this
out in less than two minutes and it will
save you a ton of time and headache in
the future this has been a public
service announcement from causes
and you guys have a great week
[Music]